Am 23 07 2014 war es soweit in kleinen tellern der hochebene in der östlichen antarktis wurde der extremste kälterekord gemessen
minus
98,6 grad celsius waren es damals in der polarnacht eisiger kann es wohl auf der erdoberfläche auch nicht werden da sind sich
forschungsteams sicher hier zu atmen würde lebensgefahr bedeuten bronchien und lungen gefäße
würden verkrampfen doch das ist nicht der einzig wirklich extreme ort auf dieser welt wurde auf der erde regnet es sind 37 jahren nur viermal
und wo ist der wind so stark
dass man ihnen nicht mal messen kann die top-5 extremst orte auf der erde jetzt den blick zum science fiction hier gibt's täglich science videos
abonniert den kanal dann verpasst der kein okay let's go herzlich willkommen
Den bisherigen kälterekord hatten satelliten messungen der nasa an einem eher drücken in der nähe von dome argus einer hochebene in der antarktis
gemessen minus 93,2 grad celsius wurden hier am 10 august
2010 gemessen dort sind es also knapp 50 grad kälter als in sibirien die krasse keller entstand wohl durch die große höhe über dem meeresspiegel
gepaart mit einem wolkenfreien mit doch dieser rekord ist jetzt geschichte wie neue auswertung der sozialisten messung zeigt und
98,6 grad am
23.7 2014 war unglaublich das forschungsteam aussehen usa erklärt die besonders krasse kälte mit mehreren faktoren die wohl zu diesem
zeitpunkt zusammen kamen zum einen kann die wärme ohne wolken direkt vom höhenrücken ins all steigen zudem
kalte luft ist schwerer als warme so war sie wohl
angetrieben durch die schwerkraft in diese senken gerutscht hinzu kamen nach angaben der forscher und forscherinnen
außerdem eine extrem trockene luft so dass die wärme der schneeoberfläche
leichter ins alt treten konnte einen kleinen wermutstropfen gibt es dennoch die weltorganisation für meteorologie
zeigt sich unbeeindruckt und erkennt diese neuen rekord kälte
nicht an da sie direkt auf dem eis gemessen wurden und eben nicht in der luft ihre ansicht nach liegt der rekord bei minus
89,2 grad celsius diese temperatur wurde im juli
983 in der arktis gemessen übrigens der kälteste dauerhaft bewohnte ort der erde liegt in der sibirischen siegling
bäumen ya konan winter sind es dort bis zu minus
67,8 grad celsius im sommer dagegen das krasse gegenteil dann können es auch mal 30 grad und mehr wert platz 4 der
trockenste ort der welt
perfektes testgebiet für den mars rover das wirklich kaum vorstellbar selbst für diejenigen unter euch die
regen verabscheuen in einer bestimmten region der atacama wüste in chile richtet ist nur viermal und das in
37 jahren in die anden blocken jegliche niederschläge ab also das gibt dort geht es so unvorstellbar trocken dass die nasa die region
216 als perfektes
testgebiet für den mars rover erklärt hat zwar ist es hier mit mehr als 100 grad mehr deutlich wärmer als auf dem mars aber
dennoch ist sich die boden beschaffung ziemlich ähnlich deswegen hat die nasa hier auch beispielsweise einige bohr technologien getestet die
zukünftig auch auf dem mars angewendet werden könnten zudem wurden auch proben gesammelt um diese im labor auf extreme
mikroorganismen zu analysieren in der gesamten atacama-wüste herrscht
wasserarmut also die trockenste wüste der welt als das gilt sicher doch trotzdem leben hier in den sehr seltenen
rasen auch einige wenige menschen platz 3 der wichtigste ort der welt windböen bis zu
240 kilometer pro stunde hier gucken wir wie auch beim platz fünf in die antarktis denn hier gibt es ganz besondere winde wie dem
kathartischen wind zb vereinfacht gesagt ist das ein
konzentrierter strom aus eisiger luft ein sogenannter
fallwind der folgendermaßen entsteht unter einer eisfläche etwa eines gletschers oder eines gebirges
kühlt sich die luft ab und deren dichte nimmt zu es entsteht eine
druckausgleich strömung an eröffnung dann natürlich mit der wärme und umgebung und der besonders kalte
kathartische fallwind entsteht nur 12 bis 19 13 hat sie sich ein forschungsteam dorthin begeben und hatte die
48 kilometer breite bucht entdeckt dabei hatte das thema auf versucht die
windgeschwindigkeit amt dennis an der spitze der kammer im osten der antarktis zu messen dazu der
expeditionsleiter von damals das klima erwies sich das ganze jahr hindurch als ein
ununterbrochener schneesturm und tatsächlich
geschaltet ist sich auch heutzutage noch schwer die stärke der kadaver zwischen winde zu messen die extra
den starken winde in kombination mit den temperaturen unter null grad celsius
machen den empfindlichen messgeräten zu schaffen und so schaffte es die bucht ins guinness buch der rekorde als
winzigster ort der welt ihre durchschnittliche windgeschwindigkeit liegt demnach bei 80 kilometern pro stunde im durchschnitt die maximale
windgeschwindigkeit ist mit 240 kilometern pro stunde angegeben kaum vorstellbar dass hier tiere oder menschen leben umso kurioser dass wir vor allem
kaiserpinguine und andere pinguinarten eines ihrer wichtigsten brutgebieten
platz zwei der nächste ort der welt man sieht die hand vor augen nicht
zu den düstersten orten der welt gehören wohl die great banks vor der küste neufundlands
rund 200 tage projekt gibt es hier so krass nebel dass man gar nichts mehr sieht alles ist nur noch grau und verschwommen der grund
der warme golfstrom aus dem süden und der kalte labrador strom aus dem norden treffen aufeinander
die kühlere luftmassen können wenig wasserdampf aufnehmen sodass dieser kondensiert dabei
entsteht nebel platz eins der heißeste ort der welt dennoch
existiert hier leben mit platz eins schließen wir den kreis begonnen haben wir mit dem
kälterekord also schauen wir jetzt na logisch auf den heißesten ort dieser welt in der ludwig im iran befindet sich wohl der
hitzepol der erde und zwar mit rund 70 grad celsius plus
2005 wurde hier mit einem infrarot radiometer des satelliten aqua die
bodentemperatur ermittelt diese extreme hitze macht diesen ort zu einem eher lebensfeindlichen raum doch ein forschungsteam hat hier tatsächlich leben gefunden
skorpione zum beispiel die sich an die extremen verhältnisse angepasst haben sie ernähren sich vom tod genauer genommen von verirrten
zugvögeln die in der heißen wüstenluft sterben und einfach vom himmel fallen ein paar grad kälter
sind es dagegen im
kalifornischen death valley das tal des todes und doch gibt es hier leben obwohl sich wohl so
anfühlt wie ein backofen von innen denn im jahr 2002 wurden hier
52,8 grad celsius gemessen und das ist wissenschaftlich belegt nachts zeigte das thermometer dann nur noch
37,8 grad an menschen trifft man hier kaum nur ein paar indianer und
nationalpark ranger leben hier ja und wenn ihr dieses video spannend gefunden habt dann endet meine telefonnummer whatsapp dann bekommt ihr täglich vor allen andern
den link zum video von mir persönlich und zur begrüßung gibt es ein kleines geschenk einfach hier draufklicken und da drunter drauf klicken
wenn ihr das video sehen wo im sommer 2018
klimawandel die erde überhitzt bis dann
bleibt dran